the high price of self-loathing that is
the focus of tonight's angle
[Music]
take to be a great salesman well it
helps to have sharp communication skills
but at a minimum you need to believe in
the product that you're selling
so how does America's Chief salesmen
measure up
systemic raisins is a stain on our
nation's Soul our veins bulging
preaching the same hate
white supremacy
chanting the same Nazi
phrases clinching is pure Terror lends
for simply being black and some people
still want to do that
which people want to do that still Joe I
mean if only America could sue him for
defamation
and Biden's lieutenants would be named
as co-defendants
America has a long history of systemic
racism it is a problem
for every American the president and the
vice president ran on a very ambitious
agenda unwinding systemic racism we know
we have work to do at home
that includes addressing profound
inequities including systemic racism
with those endorsements what foreign
leader wouldn't want to follow us
now for over a year the Divine
Administration has been trying to Rally
the world to join the efforts to
sanction Russia for its invasion of
Ukraine
we build a coalition of nations from the
Atlantic to the Pacific
NATO
to the Indian Atlantic Japan and the
Pacific I mean across the across the
world
but it turns out that few countries
outside of Europe really care about what
Biden says or does about Ukraine they
don't
The Washington Post today is reporting
that the global divide on the Ukraine
war is deepening not shrinking
the world is far from United on the
issues raised by the Ukraine war the
conflict is exposed to deep Global
divide and the limits of U.S influence
over rapidly shifting World Order
evidence abounds that the effort to
isolate Putin has failed
well these facts are devastating
since the invasion our Ally India has
allowed its trade with Russia to grow by
400 percent
and nine countries in Africa in the
Middle East visited the Russian foreign
minister in recent weeks
but wait
the Biden people are going to say well
wait wait Ingram angle 141 out of 193
U.N countries voted to condemn Russia's
invasion of Ukraine
ah wait a second here's the rub
only 33 countries have imposed sanctions
on Russia and only a similar number are
sending lethal Aid to Ukraine
well no wonder Putin's GDP is projected
to be higher than ours next year
to put it all in perspective the post
notes that one well-respected survey
estimates that estimates that two-thirds
of the world's population lives in
countries that have not condemned
Russia's move into Ukraine
wait a second wait a second wasn't Mr
experience on the world stage and the
unabashed globalist Joe Biden is
supposed to make things better for
everyone
well the truth is for decades our Elites
have advanced policies that have made
China stronger made China richer and
thus more influential in the world
and these same policies have made
America weaker and less influential in
the world and on top of all that
Democrats on the left have spent a lot
of time and energy arguing that our
system was built on racism and on evil
and that about half the country because
they voted for Trump is racist and Evil
now when they said all that when they
did all that what did they think was
going to happen
you do horrible damage to the strongest
economy in the world with these idiotic
trade policies you refer to your own
fellow citizens as white supremacist
super Maga far-right Christian
nationalists even compare parents to
domestic terrorists you keep repeating
the nonsense that democracy is under
attack and you expect that the world is
going to Rally to us and then say yeah
let's follow those guys into another War
Iraq and Afghanistan were such
resounding successes
well the former Indian foreign secretary
Conwell sebaugh put it this way
the rest of the world genuinely sees
this as a European War they do not see a
global conflict or the way it's
presented by the West
and then there's South Africa now
remember we're their biggest
post-apartheid foreign investor so one
would think that South Africa is on our
side in Ukraine right
oh well after initially claiming to be
neutral on the war there are currently
right now conducting military drills
with both Russia and China
now this was after the bite
Administration sent a formal warning to
South Africa after we suspected one of
their companies of funneling ammunition
to Russia
by the way the South African defense
minister didn't even bother replying to
our warning
now what does it say about the Biden
Administration
that they can't even get their phone
calls returned
now to use a favorite word of Biden's
look
resentment toward America that's nothing
new
but what is new is that we now have a
white house that resents America too
when the US has a strong economy a
powerful military and a proud America
first president
the rest of the world is forced to pay
attention whether they like us or not
unfortunately now
they're just paying us lip service
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else